This summer, we're getting honest about summer blockbusters past and present.
This is honest trailers. Blockbuster summer.
This episode is sponsored by CBS all access,
not at all. Based on the classic scifi novel comes the film that made you say,
Ooh, rah. When it first came out, then,
oh, I get it. When you watched a few years later, Hey,
attention Starship troopers dress up like
master chiefs, broke boy, cousin for this bugs versus apes war epic.
That satirizes what life is like in a militarized society where it costs an arm
and a leg to vote. Every channel is Fox.
News justice. The big.
Villain is every fascist secret fear of a Jina that can think for
itself,
not there might be a brain tug on P and full racial and gender equality exist
because we're all too horned up on genocide.
Can I say kill them all. Edit.
Anyone. Think the guy behind Robocop made a sincere film about sexy troops.
There's a child soldier in the first 45 seconds.
Meet a cast of teenagers who put the Hotsy and Nazi as they follow
their off to a space war.
Joined up for her. I wouldn't even be here if it wasn't for her there's.
Rico, the bold leader who will literally do anything,
his favorite teacher tells them to.
And we mean anything.
I never pass up a thing. I could 20 minutes. Yes, sir.
Carmen, who's just the worst.
I'm gonna go career. I don't think that's gonna leave a lot of room for you,
Johnny. You know what I want? Like, do you want.
Neil Patrick Harris back when he was still trying to break out of the nerd
roles, but it's still a math geek with a pet ferret Goldbug mom,
plus a bunch of supporting characters who desperately want to have sex with all
of them.
Evil space books are on the attack because they hate our freedom or because we
started colonizing their planets tomato tomato.
Now they're sending hoards of fierce warriors who can withstand a hail of
gunfire.
[Inaudible].
Or like have a clip with the pod, demands it
in beautifully crafted battle scenes that still fool the eye. 20 years later,
blending the meticulous use of CGI with the repulsive neon goo.
They used to mix monster energy.
Hey, motor movies use real goo. He can't fake good goo his stomach.
Enjoy some of the greatest line readings in film history. That's good.
Good deliver with such sincerity.
You wonder if the cast is even in on the joke.
Bunks, whacked, just as.
Everyone commits so hard, you'll be ready to enlist in the space force.
I mean mobile infantry,
because even though they're making fun of how dumb this culture is,
who wouldn't want to play some taser tag than cool over the nice group co-ed
shower. Just look at all these soapy private sub dot privates.
So enjoy a work of subversive genius.
That was definitely misunderstood when it came out,
but now enough time has passed for the world to realize it's not a dumb war
movie. It's just a movie about using war to take advantage of dumb people.
What did you say? Private Lieutenant.
Rico? Sorry. I, uh, I was just trying to make a joke.
Just trying to make a joke, sir, sir. Just trying to make a joke, sir.
Do you see me laughing, sir? No, sir. I have one rule in this unit.
Nobody quits. Every joke hits. Is that Claire, sir? Yes, sir. Handover your mic.
Private. Oh, take it from here. Yes, sir.
Starry battle star Galactica.
She wants the dues.
Where in the world is Carmen Buenos Aires. I'm with UC.
Get out of my head. Do gait shot for teacher. Whoa,
it's hang from breaking bad.
I love that show StarCraft and my desire to know
more intense of eyes saving private Rico.
Nicely done. Sir.
Honest trailers does the writing mobile infantry does the dying epic voice
guy. Welcome to the roughnecks. Rico's rough decks.
This episode is sponsored by CBS all access watch star Trek, lower decks,
starting Thursday, August 6th, exclusively on CBS, all access,
no animals were harmed in the making of the honest trailer,
other than the editor and the boys. You want to get nuts? Come on,
let's get dots.